hey guys today i'm going to show you
guys now how to
change the icons used for different
applications in your rocket dock
as you can see first of all i have a few
different icons for for [ __ ] by changing
to a photoshop icon changed my chameleon
icon and renamed it
i changed a few different things the
windows media player icon also renamed
it utorrent icon
control panel so i'm going to show you
guys how to change and rename your icons
in your rocket dock
first of all we need to open a web
browser and find an icon that we
actually like if we don't actually have
it on our computer
so a lot of good icons will actually
create on the website i'm about to show
you so if you like it go ahead and
utilize this
i'm going to direct you to
well first of all google search
rocketdoc and the first link will be
rocketdoc.com
and hopefully we won't get that hold on
all right and rocketdoc.com we just
click on this
and it'll bring us to
the rocketdoc.com website obviously and
we're going to hit the button that says
get add-ons
and that'll take us to the get add-ons
page where there's a lot of cool icons
that we can download quite easily
so first of all i'm going to pick an
icon that i want to change say i want to
change the cam studio icon i'm going to
hit icons here and i'm going to search
for cam studio see if anyone's created
any here's a nice cam studio icon
and i want to use it here so i'm going
to go through the process of replacing
that icon right there with this one so i
click on it or click on the title
and there should be a download file
exclamation mark right here click on
that to download the file
so we're going to download it and open
it with windows explorer okay
it downloads it finishes it scans it for
viruses hopefully we won't find any we
haven't good
so right here we're going to extract all
files and i'm going to extract it to
something i can remember so i'm going to
go into my
documents and program documents and hit
okay so i've saved it to my documents
and file called program documents inside
my documents and i check the show
extracted files when complete so that we
can just verify that it's actually been
actually been placed there
so it's going to go ahead and copy these
items in
extracting and it's done so this is the
actual
this is the actual
program documents folder and
hopefully
we will find it in here
but we just downloaded here we go cam
studio icons
and these are that's the actual pack
that we just found
so i'm going to try to use i want to use
it actually i like this one better um
i'll use one of these so we're going to
exit this out exit
and exit the web browser because we no
longer need it
so right now what we want to do is right
click on the icon we're placing and
press icon settings which will bring up
the icon settings menu
from here
these are the icons that are built in
but we're not using any of these so
we're going to hit plus
and again search marcus which is me
documents and
program documents click on it and hit ok
and here it is i already had it here so
there's two no worries this is a
document this is the icon that we were
replacing
click on it
or actually that's a good point we
should open that up and find cam studio
icons which came with its own pack and i
want to replace it again with this image
remember that
all you have to do is hit ok
and if you look back up here it has been
replaced with that image i actually
don't like it so i'm going to change it
to
this little handy cam here
so there it is cam studio with the same
name has been changed that's icon
um if i want to change the name of it
easy just go to here name and name it
whatever you want
i like just keep the namecam studio hit
enter or press ok
and you will have that cam studio name
right there
so um
that's pretty much it i've changed a lot
of the icons in here
to different ones that i like maybe i
want to change the internet explorer
icon open up any web browser and you saw
what i did before i'll just do one more
time for internet internet explorer to
make the process different if you didn't
actually get a pack of icons if you just
get one icon
so rocketdoc.com
and
get add-ons
and icons
and
internet explorer
hmm that's a pretty neat icon i'm going
to use that actually no
let's see what is it now this one
i will use
that's a lot there's a lot of icons here
by the way there's 48 pages of icons
that we saw at the bottom
so i'm going to use this one
click on it or click on its name
download the file open with windows
explorer which is good
first wait for those
wait for the virus scan to begin there
are no viruses so i'll exit out click on
it extract all files
to
a place that you can remember
so
there it's good
extract
and it is done extracting and instead of
actually being a folder of camstudio
icon this one is just one
internet explorer jpeg
so exit exit and exit
right click on the icon i want to
replace icon settings
and just click on
uh the actual place where you saved it
and it should be right in there so there
is the original icon
there's the one we're replacing it with
it's replaced it i like the name
hit okay
and there's the icon it's been changed
so that's a simple way to change the
icons in cam studio and the names so i
hope you like this tutorial if you got
any other ideas for tutorials that you'd
like me to record
just hit me up with a personal message
i'll try to answer it the best i can in
a video so um thanks for watching
subscribe peace
you